[Musique] les
rêves sont les graines de l'action, nous ferions tous
bien de nous rappeler qu'une
course en solitaire autour du monde lui a déjà
envoyé mon formulaire d'inscription, puis-je souligner que vous
n'avez pas de bateau capable d'un tel
voyage, nous sommes  va en construire un, est-ce que tu as déjà
fait quelque chose comme ça avant que ce soit
le point si je peux le faire alors le
gars qui regarde l'horizon peut le faire, mais je
mets de l'argent, il ne nommerait pas
tout le reste trompé par quelque chose -
pensant que nous  venais de construire un bateau,
je ne pensais pas que j'aurais à
vous regarder partir, la pression régulière tombe sur
l'homme seul sur un bateau dans la mer,
sans pitié là où les leaders 3 000 milles
et si je vais sur mes chances de survie
serait 50/50 ils aimeraient qu'ils reviennent je fais
face à certains droits
je ne peux pas continuer
Je pensais que je pourrais mieux jouer au jeu,
toujours connecté, peu importe la distance qui
me sépare maintenant demain et à jamais  e jour après que mes
enfants auront encore besoin de leur père
j'aurai encore besoin de mon mari la vie doit être
vécue la question devient que pouvez-vous faire
lui donner un sens ancien
vous